und das steht eigentlich immer schon für
qualität das haben wir jetzt erst bei
drei exemplaren das waren 1200 ews und
ist auch die 10.000 hier wäre es also
bei einem keks oder nicht so ist die
kann ich schon gar nicht mehr ernst
nehmen muss ich sagen hey was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
youtube video ja da will ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut
heute habe ich was wirklich sehr sehr
cooles vor wir machen heute zwei videos
es geht wieder um das thema airports ich
weiß viele von euch sagen wahrscheinlich
alex irgendwann reicht's noch mal sehr
viele sagen aber auch ich schaue mir das
gerne an und für die vielen die sagen
ich schaue mir gern mache ich natürlich
auch diese videos weil es mir persönlich
auch spaß macht das heißt alle die da
keinen bock mehr drauf haben ist
vollkommen in ordnung
könnte heute morgen wieder einschalten
um 19 uhr und während wir uns hinsetzen
kann ich noch ganz schnell darauf
aufmerksam machen dass hier alle ganz
fleißig den kanal abonnieren soll 3 wir
sind schon 970.000 es fehlen jetzt nur
noch 30.000 wir haben jeden tag kommt
schon 1000 neue dazu das heißt wenn es
gut läuft 30 tage ganz kurz auf
abonnieren klicken und dann machte mich
ganz wirklich
wir fangen heute mit folgendem thema an
ich habe da gerade bei reingeguckt das
ding ist nämlich weiß ich nicht es ist
am besten erklären vielleicht zeige ich
euch mal ganz kurz diese mail ich bin es
immer einen dir aleks wie huawei ideos
fantasy youtube produkten in ihrem orden
remix wasserfall herrenteam der
videorekorder kenny chen yuan very happy
to contribute to me is you can follow
ich habe keine ahnung wie das ist immer
so das problem diese leute die nicht aus
deutschland kommen um irgendein produkt
schicken wollen die haben immer so
ansprüche dass wenn die mir also ein
kleines produkt stehen dass ich ein
ganzes wieder darüber drehen kann und
ich habe ja wirklich mit vielen leuten
kommuniziert und der eric der weizen
bisschen sauer weil sein produkt ich
habe das produkt nie erhalten sonst
hätte ich wirklich dass auch in meine
black friday mit reingenommen falls sie
nicht gesehen haben uns immer noch da
reinzuschauen auf jeden fall habe ich
jetzt lag es dann am montag
in meinen briefkasten dieses pakete
gefunden ich habe natürlich schon
reingeguckt weil ich ist nicht zuordnen
konnte weil ich habe eigentlich keine
airport fakes mehr bestellt sollte
mittlerweile auch schon so meine zehn
exemplare sein wenn nicht sogar noch
mehr oder wenn das ding ist nämlich hier
ich habe das jetzt mal geöffnet warte
man das handy wie 10.000 tws die sollen
doch besser sie 1000 träger ist sowohl
ich bin ein bisschen aus dem konzept
gekommen
ich habe es eigentlich dachte ich das
ist praktisch vielleicht das produkt von
diesen typen der wieder geschrieben hat
jetzt habe ich hier gerade hinten
gesehen ganz klein
das sind die 10.000 tws die ich
anscheinend jede wand noch bestellt habe
die sind jetzt mit großer verzögerung
angekommen weil er könnte ja
wahrscheinlich mein video zu den 1000
ews welche ja bis jetzt die besten
airport fakes waren habe ich ja auch
immer gesagt und jedem video und ich
habe sehr oft in den kommentaren gelesen
dass ich auf jeden fall auf diese testen
soll
das team noch besser sind ob das stimmt
weiß ich nicht ich habe da hat man die
preise verglichen auf verschiedenen
seiten und diese hier sind sogar ein
bisschen teurer als die 1000 m s als ich
habe hier so bei 30 bis 35 euro gesehen
dann würde ich sagen die tasten leute
macht und ich bin extrem gespannt ob die
diese e-1000 erschlagen können wir haben
ein kleines problem und zwar habe ich
die anderen ja verlost die sind auch
nicht mehr hier
sonst würde ich die sehr gerne
vergleichen direkt aber das geht nicht
also ich kann nur mit meiner eigenen
einschätzung dann sagen ob die noch
besser sind oder mich aber dass die
schon mal gut aber dann wieder die
originalen du hast ja wieder die
originale nur die modischen koyama die
originalen
also bis jetzt will man ja mal drauf
kommen dass die schon irgend kleinen ort
gefällt mir wäre natürlich am ende auch
wieder zu 100 prozent auf insgesamt
verlost am alex wie müssen habe ich
einfach folgen die sind darin meine
story oder an sich müsste manager folgen
ist einfach nur auf die sorgen die
antworten dass sie die gerne haben
wollte und dann wird innerhalb von einer
woche mit der gewinner kontaktiert wie
immer ihr könnt das spiel dann würde ich
sagen ich habe schon wieder zu fühlen
wir wollen die mal kurz hier raus haben
wir auf jeden fall ein airport fällt der
zweiten generation meine eigenen die ich
immer noch aus der ersten
dabei kommt natürlich auch von mir
airport vor fakes die habe ich alle
schon bestellt haben wir ganz viele
verschiedene deswegen heute da auf jeden
fall drauf und machen wir erst mal so
ein bisschen enttäuscht
also ist sollte es voll in ordnung ich
weiß nicht ob auch schon mal besser
hatten aber fühlt sich sehr gut an wie
ich ja immer so schön sagen warum hast
du ist nur wie oder was wir zu sagen
dann immer einmal in die hand
diese bei denen es auf jeden fall besser
ja dieses zu klappen bleibt die mal so
heftig nach hinten auf dann wackelt das
so ein bisschen
na ja klar bei denen ja es ist nicht so
nicht so da ist er recht aber so von der
größe her und so wirklich eins zu eins
aber das hatten wir ja auch schon bei
den bei vielen anderen muss ich sagen
deswegen jetzt kommt hier heute wieder
auf den sound an ich muss sagen ich bin
auf ultra gespannt auf die airport profi
ich hoffe die kommen nächste woche dann
kann ich das direktor machen die videos
gut dann holen wir die marke aus dass
makler haben die airport projekt auch
neues kennen zu link das weiß ich nicht
ich habe dir einfach bestellt auf
verschiedenen webseiten zb spiele macht
das werden wir dann rauskriegen ich
hoffe mal vor aber ich kann es nicht
sagen so drei die haben schon 45 euro
kostet muss qualität inseln da muss
qualität also es muss zumindest in
ordnung sein für 45 euro kann man das
wir erwarten so gut vergleichen wir die
malkunst alter kommen
das ist wirklich schon man kann wirklich
überhaupt keinen unterschied erkennen
außer hier unten die kennzeichnung links
ist ein ganz ganz bisschen fitter als
bei dem original aber wenn wir die jetzt
irgendwann die hand drückt ich würde das
nicht merken dass sie fähig sind sehen
wirklich sehr sehr klein aus
dann würde ich sagen kollekten war die
mal direkt und dann kann ich auch schon
mehr zum sound sagte und werden durch
die kollekte juli du kannst wenn man
hier kurs auf diesem stapel film ja das
video machen wir nämlich gleich auch
noch und zwar weiß was da drin ist ich
habe wirklich dass internet durchstöbert
und ich habe eine seite gefunden da gibt
es die verrücktesten airport cases
eklige sachen bestellt das glaubt ihr
nicht deswegen muss auf das video
anschauen das auch getan
die verrücktesten airport cases und
jetzt connect mir das mal hier eben auch
kummer direkt schon hier zeigt direkt
klopps auf verbinden taste gedrückt
halten der post ja das ging schon mal
schneller muss ich sagen aber wir haben
ja auch direkt wieder die anzeige sieht
man nach und das steht eigentlich immer
schon für qualität das hatten wir jetzt
erst bei drei exemplaren des hlg 1000
events die 200 mb s und ist auch die
10.000 hier wäre es also bei allen fans
oder nicht so ist die kann ich so gar
nicht mehr ernst nehmen muss ich sagen
okay ich muss sagen ich habe die gerade
ans ohr gesteckt und deswegen direkt die
musiker das heißt wir haben hier wieder
so einen sensor drin der das erkennt das
ja auch schon mal das ist richtig gut
das hatten wir nämlich ich bin mir nicht
mehr sicher ob es bald 1000 rat muss ich
nachschauen
wenn ihr es wisst dann ist es gut ich
kann dich schreibt vielleicht hier rein
ich schreibe es kurz hier ein paar leute
hab ich noch vergessen zu sagen hier
könnte es ja sehen weil es charts
funktioniert das eigentlich auch ganz
meist aber ich meine nicht aus denn kein
track ich keinen guten von links thiago
silva juni ist dann kann man schon mal
auf das motiv ein super
[Applaus]
die musik hat aufgehört also das ist
wirklich schon mal krass das ist
wirklich krass jetzt geht es mir jetzt
nicht mehr
der sensor ist nicht so gut da weil es
bei apple aus zu binden sie sind somit
der hand zu hell jaja geladen aber ich
habe gerade meinen finger hier irgendwie
weiß naja gut ist gar nicht mal schlimm
trotzdem gibt es ihn und das ja schon
mal schön
der bass ist gut was das sind die ersten
wo ich wo ich direkt denken okay der
basis vorhanden und er ist der hört sich
gut an
ok
[Applaus]
weil mal ganz kurz und anderes wird er
in ein anderes genre geht also ich muss
wirklich sagen bin wirklich begeistert
sommer ein sommer denn dein empfinden ob
das bis jetzt die besten sind nicht nur
der linke der linke du legst du machst
du das liegt an dir also bei mir ich
will mit der ich glaube vor führungs
effekt ich verstehe ja dass konnten
dauert irgendwie mal ein bisschen
verbindung fehlgeschlagen flop so auch
so jetzt hab ich's gefixt
davor wie vor im song schreiber nicht so
kritisch im blick ist kein schlechter
klang aber ja das weiß ich ja aber ist
es besser als die die wir davor heinz
baumann ist und die tausend dinge ich
weiß es halt nicht mehr ganz genau aber
ich glaube die waren ich würde sehr
ähnlich gut einstufen
ich glaube die hatten kein schlechter
sogar wenn du was sagst dann ist das so
aber die hatten glaube ich keinen selbst
ja das kann ja wieder für die sprechen
ja deswegen ist es schwierig also ich
würde sagen vom sound her tut sich da
nicht viel die sind auf jeden fall in
ordnung für das geld ich mein ich habe
da 30 euro für bezahlt werden wir noch
gar nicht reingeschaut gemacht ich habe
hier mein nächstes leiden den kabel von
apple oder halt zumindest für apple
geräte von apple ist es ja
wahrscheinlich nicht also ich bin auf
jeden fall überzeugt muss ich sagen für
das geld muss man kurz nach schulschluss
bezahlt hat oder die haben 24 eur 990
dafür zahlt die tausend dinge waren auf
jeden fall teurer wobei da kommt so
immer dann auf die seite an also wenn
ich die wieder für das geld finde
verlinkt ist auf jeden fall in der video
beschreibung und ja also ich denke wenn
ihr alternativen gemacht die damit auf
jeden fall nichts falsch machen mal auf
kurs zum mikrofon scheck oder hast du
dein handy
[Applaus]
gut aufgelegt ich habe mich aufgelegt
auf die kopfhörer drauf drückt
automatisch die waren das dauert ist ja
auch egal ob echt nicht gut war nicht
gut sagt man manchmal sind markus passt
irgendwie in langen satz kurs
und jetzt die richtigen seit zehn jahren
hätten können du hast recht ich versteh
nicht glauben dass er jetzt hier nicht
raus soll man man so eine scheiße ich
habe mich schon eigentlich dachte ich
das sind geile dinge na ja ich fand die
musik eigentlich in ordnung muss ich ja
aber das telefonat ja das telefon
nachweis nicht oder gelbe vormachen also
ich muss sagen für musik kann man die
empfehlen 24 eur 990 vielleicht kriegt
man nirgendwo noch günstiger aber die
schlagen vermutlich dann doch nicht die
1000 m
leider muss ich ehrlich sein zu euch
obwohl ich glaube dass ich bete
herausgekommen sind lassen noch nach
oben da wir sehen uns dann auf jeden
fall morgen 19 wieder abonniert den
kanal und wir drehen jetzt noch das
airport case video
juli das will ich so begeistert diese
hüllen nicht gefunden habt wirklich das
ist das heftigste und wieder einschalten
instagram alex wieder werden jetzt in
meiner story verlost und haut rein